so many of the things that I say are
contradictions that I believe in very
opposite points of view I like pulling
from both directions this one is very
noble and one is very selfish ego
humility I don't care what anybody
thinks about me I care about what
everybody thinks about me right
can't get too ahead of yourself you
can't go too slow I am massively patient
but on a practical level and an
execution level I'm very fast
I love Lourdes bond but then when
somebody actually does that and doesn't
deliver on it in a weird way I'm okay
with that
I'm never too fancy I can go to the
owners dinner at the NFL like Super Bowl
and the next day like go give a talk at
some high school for fruit like it's
like you know when in hip-hop somebody
gets big yo the streets don't [ __ ] with
you anymore
yeah in business world I want the
streets to [ __ ] love me more than
life yet I want to be the fancy
businessman that's on the cover of Time
magazine all that ambition needs to be
equally balanced with patience patience
and speed are very much rubbing against
each other but it's like the diamond
comes from right it's about finding that
cadence and balance the guide through
that's what works for me the truth is I
have a feeling this works very
differently for everyone
you